[Music]
>> Hi, I'm Tanvi Surti, a
program manager on the Microsoft
Translator Team, and I'm here to
tell you about a new product
from the team called Microsoft
Translator Live.
It's the world's first group
conversation translation tool,
and you must notice that as I'm
speaking the transcription of
what I'm saying is showing up
right here.
It's not completely accurate.
But you'll see that it's getting
most of what I'm saying.
And as I'm speaking, along with
the English, on the left you
also see the Chinese.
So this is a live translation of
what I'm saying in English in
Chinese.
And this is a really crucial
tool for education scenarios,
for business scenarios, for
travel scenarios, where two or
more people speaking multiple
languages need to talk to one
another.
So let me give you another
example of how someone on their
smartphone could connect into
this conversation.
So right here I have the
Microsoft Translator app on my
Android device.
I am going to look at my
conversation code here and pull
up the QR code.
And using my device here, I'm
going to scan the QR code.
And select French as my language
here.
I don't speak very much French
but just about to get by.
So, [speaking in French].
So as you see here, you see the
French of what I -- I broke
this, nice -- you see the French
of, what I said in French
showing up here in English, and
what I'm saying in English shows
up here in French, and as before
it continues to show up here in
Chinese.
So this is not just a demo.
It's a real product today.
Download it on Android, iOS,
Windows, PowerPoint and Web.
Look for Microsoft Translator,
the app, on your smartphone of
choice.
Thank you very much.